[Music]  one day I will swallow  and you look like [ __ ]  always you have pissed away your talent  on women and boozing  that's what feeds the juices up here in  my noggin man I get all these things  going they start to your music the  world's reverberating back and forth and  hit the frequencies  I start to dance to it and my fingers  get moving  spinning on the [ __ ] place  and the [ __ ] words come out  [Music]  girl stops now the foolishness  you got to publish your novel and if you  mess this up it's jail time  wish me luck I'm off to write the next  great American novel let me have a  gangbang when I get back I will invite  your mother thank you Miss Moore dog I'm  trying to uncover my connection with the  world  just follow me my friend let's go where  see the pilot mom and you got like home  and Buffy sighs perfect shoe something  shoot this in here now I gotta feed my  Colt addicted Hey  [Music]  [Music]  you